Deli has been gripped by space fever and
this is what everyone here is getting
excited about on Monday India will
launch Chandrayaan to its second lunar
mission its aim is to land a rover on an
as yet unexplored part of the moon this
is a few steps forward in terms of
having an orbiter with advanced play
notes and then a lander which would soft
land on the moon plus a rover which
would move around and no detail in situ
studies in 2008 India's first moon
mission chandrayaan-1 orbited the moon
and helped confirm the presence of water
but it didn't make a landing under Prime
Minister Narendra Modi the country has
stepped up its ambitions in space 2013
saw India's first interplanetary venture
the launch of an orbiter to Mars with
this latest mission India wants to
cement its status as a leader in space
technology by becoming only the fourth
country in the world to perform a soft
landing and put a rover on the moon and
it has even more ambitious plans the
first manned mission into space is
scheduled for 2022 and soon after that
the creation of India's own Space
Station and someone with intimate
knowledge of India's plans for space and
the upcoming chandrayaan-2 mission is
science journalist and author Paula
Paula Paula good to have you on the
program now India plans to land the
rover on the South Pole of the moon how
significant is that landing on the South
Pole of the moon is very significant and
no other country has till date gone as
close to the South Pole as India is
going if you recall most of the landings
for the Apollo missions have happened
equatorial region the only country which
has gone anywhere close to the South
Pole is China which is on the far side
of the moon but it is still closer to
the equatorial region the Indian
spacecraft is going closest to the South
Pole but why are they going there
that's a very valid question they're
going there because that is an
unexplored area and India hopes to do
some good science and hopefully some
good discovery which could include
finding copious amounts of water on the
South Pole of the Moon which is what
scientists are predicted so India has
chosen fully the landing site very close
to the South Pole of the moon but still
not on the South Pole now India's also
announced plans to send astronauts into
space and also build a space station
what exactly are the aims of India's
space program what does it hope to
achieve but very straightforward India's
space program is meant for benefiting
the 1.3 billion Indian population the
plan the Indian Space Agency focuses
very heavily on meeting the needs of the
common people from which a small part of
the budget is taken out and used for
blue sky work and along which the human
spaceflight program is one part going to
the Moon or Mars or finally trying to
set up a Space Station which could
happen as 2030 these are all parts of
India preparing knowledge ease so that
English not be left behind in times to
come right Paula partner will have to
leave it there for the time being but
thanks very much for explaining that to
us